this is a book just recently published
by professor psychology at Harvard named
Steven Pinker very highly respected
figure it's called the better angels of
our nature why violence has declined it
is a an interesting argument that he
makes which is that for the long
duration of human existence as a species
there has been a steady decrease in the
incidence of violence for the earliest
periods he goes to archaeological sites
and looks at the proportion of skeletons
that show signs of being killed by
violence as he moves forward in time he
gets into more other sorts of data but
it's a book that is very heavily
quantitative highly theoretical and
designed to provoke a certain amount of
skepticism I think in other words I
think he's aware that he has to sell
this idea of a long-term decline in
violence
partly because it comes to Center
eventually on the question of whether
the 20th century was a particularly
violent time
forty million I think it's the number he
goes so I want to talk about the the
types of arguments get that get involved
here because they're directly relevant
not just to the whole question of world
wars one and two but to what he refers
to as the long piece that is to say
history of Europe since 1945 the
argument there is over whether the 20th
century was in a long term trend a time
of low violence that happen to have some
anomalies namely World War one and World
War two and that the long piece is the
natural continue a tour that is to say
that in the future there will be a few
wars that are even remotely comparable
in terms of loss of life with the ones
we've seen in the past or whether there
are one has to regard World Wars 1 and 2
as being really really really bad you
know wars that killed a lot of people
and we see no reason why that should
should be the end of it going back to
the world war one slogan of a war to end
all wars is there any reason to think
that war is finished and that when we
look at the second half of the 20th
century we should see if not as a post
war era in the sense of being post World
War two but a post war era in the sense
of wars being now
diminished in their significance one of
the virtues of Pinker's approach from
his point of view is that he focuses
overwhelmingly on Europe whereas the
Rwanda Holocaust and other really
regrettable events are not European and
don't fall into the category of war in
the fashion and he's talking about it
but let me give a little bit of the the
way he constructs this and some of the
things that are that are pertinent to it
he is a Hobbesian as far as I can tell I
have not read the entire book I've gone
into it here and there but as clearly he
is a believer that Thomas Hobbes
was right and that in the primitive
state of mankind you had a war of all
against all that warfare was the common
experience and that the corollary of
course is that States reduce the
probability of war or the lethality of
war this is a highly debated issue among
anthropologists and partly because the
the archaeological record is ambiguous
that is to say you don't have all of the
skeletons you don't have necessarily a
very clear notion of
the time period over which violent
deaths occurred you simply don't have a
context simply you have skeletons and
show signs of death by violence and when
you come to the foraging period of human
existence which has both the
archaeological component and the modern
ethnographic component where people have
observed societies and made appraisals
of how violent those societies are there
you get some substantial debates
probably the best-known debate deals
with an Amazon tribe namely Yanomamo
they were studied by a anthropologist
named Napoleon chanyeol and he portrays
them as being continually at war his
book on the yanomamö came out in the 60s
and became the most oh the best-selling
and widely used book in in anthropology
and it in almost any book you read about
the history of warfare chapter one will
deal with nowadays with the yanomamö
because they're taken as being a pre
contact foraging pre-contact meaning pre
European Association foraging culture
that engaged in continuous and
particularly lethal warfare chanyeol
describes them as being
it's not fighting for food or territory
but for women he quotes one of the
Chiefs is saying you know we like meat
but we like women more and and then he
argued that the the chief the victors
ended up having more children than the
vanquished and therefore it became a
sort of a Darwinian thing where warfare
was a way of ensuring that your DNA
would be passed on and for people who
are oriented toward sociobiology this
suggests sort of a continuum between
chimpanzee behavior though not bonobos
behavior and and human behavior now
there have been half-a-dozen
anthropologists who have subsequently
rigid about Yama yanomamö warfare all of
them disagreeing in one way or another
in along different lines with Sonia and
Sean Young has been barred from ever
going back to yanomamö territory by the
Catholic missionaries who now have
authority over the territory and they
have written their own appraisals of the
yanomamö it is very contentious
descriptions of meetings where this
comes up seem to include people
screaming and shouting and calling one
another wires and Nazis and so forth but
the fact of the matter is that there are
other descriptions of in the
ethnographic literature of other
foraging societies that have high high
rates of warfare or at least of death by
violence
the question in a sense is and it's
always a question when you use a
photography as a stand-in for archeology
is whether a foraging group observed in
the 20th century is behaving the same
for at least in general or analogously
in the way a foraging group of 40
thousand years ago would have behaved
and one of the indicators that this may
not be the most reliable thing to go on
is the fact that there aren't many
foragers left you might say that you
know you could argue perhaps that all
the peaceful foragers settled down and
bought stock and you know now live off
their proceeds and it's only the really
violent ones that are left probably not
true but I mean there there has to be
some cognizance taken of the fact that
the surviving societies are in in many
cases some of the most inhospitable
environments and most challenging
environments so it's not very clear but
but of course there are certain things
that are that you also have to take anew
in into account if you have a dispute
where there is no state where there is
no law what do you do other than kill
the other guy we are there's no prison
there's no you know no system of fines
because there is no monetary system and
to some degree you can argue that
killing takes place because it's the
only alternative you don't have other
ways to to sanction other people
there are of course other ways to look
at it for example you could say you
could exile someone as we know happens
in early state formations and to some
agreein in some anthropological context
but some of the violence may come about
simply because that's the only recourse
you have then you get into the issue of
states and Pinker moves in fairly
quickly into the notion of Europe and
particularly focuses on statistics that
were gathered first by at Edgar and then
by others indicating that between 1400
and say 1900 the rate of homicide in
England fell by orders of magnitude it
has to be displayed on a logarithmic
scale because you'd have like a hundred
people per hundred thousand per year
being killed by homicide and in 1400 and
here down to like five by the time you
got to to 1900 and they're similar
curves not a quite as dramatic for other
European countries so the argument is
that violence as measured by homicide
declines that doesn't mean that war
necessarily declines but rather homicide
in terms of individuals killing other
individuals and again you have the the
issue of what the alternatives are that
if you're going to have a punitive
regime what can you do other than kill
someone eventually you get prisons
eventually you get
other sorts of punishments like sending
someone to Australia or something like
that but presumably there's a time where
where death or dismemberment were the
only real sanctions that you had and
that's not too too hard to understand so
institutionally I think one can see why
a homicide per se would perhaps diminish
but Pinker moves in a different
direction and he relies very heavily on
the thinking of a sociologist
named Norbert Norbert Elias a German
sociologist who fled Germany as a Jew
with the rise of Nazism and settled
England where he had a whole variety of
kind of adjunct type teaching jobs never
became a particular star and indeed was
not even noticed very much until the
last 10 years or so of his life he died
I believe in 1990 his the book that has
given him Fame now is called the
civilizing process and he wrote it in
1939 a bad year to write about the
civilizing process it was not
surprisingly ignored until it was
translated into English in 1969 then in
sort of a meteoric fashion Elias became
one of the Giants of sociology who had
been overlooked a little bit in the way
that machs Weber got adopted at an
earlier point or that Herbert Spencer
got vilified at a certain point but
Elias
sought to explain why violence vanished
in Europe over a period of six or seven
hundred years and I'm here talking about
not about warfare per se but about
propensity to engage in violent activity
the civilizing process for him uses the
notion of civil civilized that you have
in sort of Italian she built on the idea
that a civilized person is a cultured
person as a person who has adopted the
manners and inculcated the the mental
outlook of being a civilized being so
he's interested in things like table
manners standards of personal behavior
you know do you act abusively or is it
considered wrong to do so and he sort of
tries to chart these over a period of
century centuries to see that the
Europeans became less and less barbaric
to use a somewhat loaded term over that
period of centuries in his last book
which allows his last book published
during his lifetime which is a study
translated English as the Germans as a
study of of his fellow countrymen he
focuses very heavily on dueling and on
the the disappearance of dueling says
the dueling becomes kind of a a
benchmark of where the society stands
the respect to resort to violence
and he faults Germany for being very
late in outlawing dueling compared with
other European countries and it's a book
full of details about dueling for Pinker
what Elias suggests is that some major
transformation in European society led
to a diminishment of violence over a
period of centuries so that raises the
question of what the change was in
European society Elias suggests that
it's the move from feudal life to more
centralized state life then you get to
the Enlightenment and to the rise
particularly in the 18th and 19th
centuries of notions of humane behavior
so forth and so on so in a sense the
diminishment of violence is seen as a
consequence of the whole master
narrative of Western European history
that has been traditional in courses on
Western civilization my words it isn't
simply Western civilization as a place
but it's Western civilization as a you
know as a way of life
so Pinker runs the risk here of coming
up with a theory that although
buttressed by enormous amounts of
statistical or at least quantified
information come have a theory that
basically says Europe is really
wonderful and
so let's not talk about the rest of the
world because he has a hard time talking
about the rest of the world the
quantification has not been done the
primary sources are not readily
available when he has a list that he
picks up from some other researcher of
the twenty worst villainies perpetrated
by humans against other humans he he
lists among the top twenty is a number
of lives lost through Middle East slave
trading and something like fifteen
million more people more lives lost
through slave trading in the Middle East
than her loss to slave trading in the
Atlantic according to this list I have
never run across any statistics that
would even remotely support this idea
what it results from I'm pretty sure is
some travelers observationally
particularly Henrik Barth who travelled
extensively in the Sahara and witnessed
slave caravans moving from Chad Mali
Nazaire northward across the Sahara a
lot of human life was lost because of
the difficulty of the passage and a lot
of people were presumably killed in some
other fashion I don't know exactly how I
don't see why slave trading would
promote killing particularly when North
Africa the destination the destination
did not have sugar plantations or other
types of farming economy that tended to
be lethal to slave but nevertheless I
think what happened was that somebody
took this sort of observation and simply
multiplied it by the number of years
that that they might plausibly think
there had been Saharan trade
the multiplier that that Pinker refers
to is I think Cameron works about a
thousand years or so or 1500 anyway goes
well before Islam as if we can simply
take an account for the 19th century and
simply extrapolate and come up with a
number which we will then put on a chart
that will then be digested by a
psychologist and say this tells you
something similarly with the forty
million people killed in the Mongol
conquest he mentions a million and a
half killed in the city of Murph city of
mariga's and Oasis and the Karakum
desert that has never had a million and
a half inhabitants may have had a couple
of hundred thousand doubt I doubt they
were all killed but he takes all the
numbers from Persian chronicles that
were designed to create horror feelings
about the Mongols so the problem with
fundamentally someone who aggregates
aggregations that are made up of other
things aggregated I mean you whatever
your fundamental error is it essentially
gets multiplied so when it comes to the
non-european data I'm extremely
skeptical of a Pinker's finding I also
find it very interesting and if you
compare say 1400 in the Islamic world
with 1900 and you look at the rate of
homicide that was to say murders and
such or even at the rate of warfare
you find that the Muslim world was
extremely peaceful homicide was not a
particularly common crime you go down
even to inner warriors in Iraq in the
20th century be statistically the most
common crime was verbal in use
which you know if you say to someone in
public your father is a dog you can be
imprisoned because that's abusive but
the idea that that people killed each
other in a commonplace fashion I've
never found any evidence that that
occurs and when I look at the European
statistics I'm struck by is not how
wonderful Europeans were at becoming
more peaceful but how barbaric they were
at the start of their curve because in
the end they become more or less more or
less peaceful except of course for one
world war two so so there are lots of
suspicious elements here but a lot of
the agenda that Pinker has worked
backwards from the business of the long
piece and whether we are now in an era
that is truly post-war or whether it is
something else in order to argue that he
has to first explain away world war one
in World War two and secondly he has to
to explain why the long piece house has
come to pass which he clearly believes
it has explaining away World War one
into says there are some people who have
argued that wars have gotten worse and
worse that there's been sort of a step
function that you had no wars that
killed you know two million then up to
five up to ten up to 30 up to 40 and
that and these sites Arnold Toynbee is
someone who says wars have gotten worse
and worse
many sites other people say that wars
are cyclical and that after a period of
peace there is a propensity for war that
grows and Wars recurs he argues that
when you look at very large collections
of war data and Harry's aggregating what
other people have aggregated without
particularly inquiring us the nature of
each a war is that's what you have is a
plutonium distribution which indicates
indicates randomness that yeah
wars occur but they don't occur
cyclically they don't occur in a step
function in terms of increasing violence
and they are not the instance of one war
should never be taken to be an indicator
of the next war any more than you would
take a flip of the coin of heads to
indicate that tails was coming up next
so he says that World War one in World
War two were truly awful but they were
random how does he account for the fact
that they occurred when they when they
occurred and here he he refers to
counter enlightenment romanticism 'he's
like Nazism and communism and the notion
of counter enlightenment is very
important for him the Enlightenment as
he sees it is a period is a movement of
rationality and systematic effort
philosophically and morally based to
discover the truth about everything
romanticism takes you out of the world
of
calculus and and careful philosophical
rulemaking and into the world of feeling
and many people have have noted that the
rise of romanticism at the turn of the
19th century is he is a counterpoint to
the to the Enlightenment rationalism of
the 18th century but he sees the the
isms that arise as being isms that are
empowered by the by the the desire or
the lure of connecting with something
that is super rational super individual
whether that something is the working
class or the state the nation or the
party or whatever you have so he he
finds that World War One in World War
two are arise from the from the
propagation of these counter
Enlightenment movements and that this
and that means burned themselves out you
know they they he evoked passions and
vocht willingness to sacrifice but
eventually it was all blood on the
battlefield and that that is more or
less over soar the end of ideology idea
so then he goes back and makes reference
to a paper written by Emanuel khat
called perpetual peace we're taught Adam
rates
we thought that a some sort of world
government or at least if not a formal
world government at least some sort of
internationalist interact and
cooperation could lay the groundwork for
a for perpetual peace and this leads him
to the - one of the great discoveries or
inventions it's hard to tell which of
the political science profession witches
the idea of the Democratic peace if you
go into political science you will be
exposed to this repeatedly by people
working in international relations so
not all of them and this maintains that
if you make a list of all wars over the
last say 300 years that there is no
instance of a democratic country going
to war with another democratic country
is that the war of 1812 but we won't
count that because we can call that kind
of a late colonial war or something and
says you know this it is so improbable
that you would have no wars between
democracies that perhaps we have here a
law that democracies do not do not go to
war except with autocracies or other
vile horrible people who deserve good
thrashing
one might ask how many democracies there
were before 1900 and that would be the
responsibility of the aggregator not of
the person who's spinning off
conclusions but you also have the
problem and this has been a fairly
recent refinement as to whether the
Democratic piece applies to
democratizing countries as opposed to
democratic countries so in other words
if if Russia goes to war with Georgia is
that a democracy going to war with
another democracy or is Georgia in the
category of a democratizing country as
maybe we were in 1812
who knows and do you have to to cut
fledgling democracies a little bit of
slack because they haven't yet studied
political science and learned that they
are not supposed to go to war
so Pinker says well let's let's take
that as a sir working hypothesis that as
the world democratizes wars will become
obsolete now let's add to it the
question of what is the relationship
between war and international trade do
countries that have trading
relationships go to war with one another
well of course they do but not with
great frequency it seems and the volume
of trade seems to be counter indicated
in other words do you every war with
with Iran when you're going to totally
screw up the entire world oil market
well maybe you do we'll probably know by
the end of next semester but there's
arguably made that there going to be
people in both countries that that will
stop this and part of it will be a major
part of will be the fact that Iran
produces so much oil that the world
cannot really do without it for a
prolonged period of time without total
total chaos instruction so picker would
say that so you have trade and democracy
tend to act against the propensity for
war and then he says the third one is
participation in interstate governmental
organizations that if you longer the
world Postal Union or the International
Olympic Committee or whatever you're
less likely to go to war because you're
in in useful contact and so for the song
so he builds up this this idea and he
raises a question of is the long piece
truly the contem state of perpetual
peace that that was visualized in the
18th century no this book has been very
highly praised in reviews of it I find
an enormous number of holes in it but
it's also extremely interesting reading
for the bits of data that it brings up
and for the other studies that brings
together it seems to me however that
when it comes to explaining the 20th
century it it really doesn't work that
you know saying you know it's just kind
of a random anomalous thing that if
Gavrilo had not assassinated Archduke
Ferdinand Archduke Ferdinand there
wouldn't have been a first world war so
there wouldn't have been a Great
Depression so it wouldn't have been a
second world war and it's his fault and
he wasn't executed he was a minor he was
put in prison and died several years
later but of the natural causes that are
so common in prison
so I have a hard time accepting the
hypothesis that we are now embarked on a
perpetual peace that is intrinsic to the
achievement of the Enlightenment what
Pinker is doing here in part is
countering a fairly long series of
attacks on the Enlightenment you may
start with Nietzsche and can certainly
add in Foucault you can add in any
number of people who have said that that
the the sort of self-congratulatory
scientism and worship of rationality in
the in the Enlightenment actually led to
bad things as well as good things and it
was not a it was not necessarily the
greatest triumph of human of human
thought and human moral achievement and
Pinker seems to be terribly desirous to
see Europe since 1945 as not only the
model for the future that other parts of
the world may slowly come to to emulate
but also as the the great triumph of
Western civilization in the long course
of history in this respect if even
though the title of the book the topic
of the book why violence has declined
seems radical the book in many ways I
think is very conservative in sort of
defending the quote we long long thought
was the great central
achievement of Western civilization but
my objections to this approach are not
simply the ones I've stated there also
I'm very troubled by the by the
assumption that agency that is to say
the actors the people who bring about
Wars are strictly governments it's
partly because as a social historian and
was someone who really believes in that
history is made by by people and not by
forces or events they coerce people in
certain ways but people are necessary
the people who create who commit
violence according to Pinker are males
between 15 and 30 so some of you are
kind of off the hook others maybe not
quite and I think that's everybody would
or less agree that that's that that's
the case and so you get to the question
of what would mitigate that sort of
thing you know Men Behaving Badly and
there are certain things that
statistically are identified as
mitigators for example the the homicide
rate and also the rate of killing and
warfare a married man is lower than of
single men partly because conscription
will often exempt married men and
probably because married men have
something to live for and they don't
want to get shot up so I think it would
suggest that you know where you have a
high rate of marriage you'll have less
less violence he doesn't connect it
directly with war
he also observes as many other people
have observed that the sex ratio is a
key factor that when you have males
outnumbering females in the youth
category that the probability of there
being war is much higher presumably
because the the number of men who cannot
find a spouse is substantial enough that
they become you know a wild crazy you
know meth snorting you know killer is
the one sort or another and there's been
some some effort to actually
substantiate this where we have records
dealing with with sex ratios one thing
that Pinker points out is that if there
is to be war in the future it may be
that the the highest probability
participants will be those in countries
that have high youth populations and a
skewed sex ratio basically China and
India where you have selective abortion
or a preference for four male children
and where the female population becomes
scarce but a youth bulge altogether is a
means that you have more youthful males
hanging around them then that's good for
you
so what do you do about youthful males
well yes that's why we award you kill
them
can't live with it let's kill them off
if you have a volunteer army in the
first place they are the volunteer army
is often not as youthful as the
conscript army but it just means that
you have a lot of youthful males hanging
around and when I look at the 20th
century which is the notional topic of
this lecture one of the things I am
struck by is that in the first half of
20th century the enormous prevalence of
uniforms of not simply men in uniform
but boys in uniform women in uniform the
idea for example the Boy Scouts start
1910 baden-powell a British General who
had fought in the Boer War in South
Africa and who was creating a youth
organization the Boy Scouts spread
spread phenomenally not to every country
in the world but say by the by the late
20s you had 30 or 40 countries that had
Scout movements the Scout movements had
uniforms they had flags they had
ideologies they usually had a passionate
association with with their national
identity
the notion of a uniform
spreads surprisingly so that saved the
new fashions for women in China in the
19's a after 1911 many of the the new
costumes are based on on uniforms bright
colors and women's clothes disappear and
you get drab colors of brown and so
forth and certainly for men who in 1900
in China had worn you know enormous Li
decorative silk brocade by the 1930s the
stylish men are wearing you know the
sort of don't look and clothes that I
wear it's you know it is creating a kind
of image that is not military but not
that far from military when I say not
that part for military I'm thinking of
someone like William Randolph Hearst the
great newspaper publisher propagandist
for the spanish-american war who started
his own scout group called the American
Boy Scouts as opposed to the Boy Scouts
of America which he identified as
strictly a military organization it was
where boys would learn to be to be
soldiers of course they would also
learned to be little Native Americans
because the idea that you were learning
how to scout to build campfires to they
don't live rough and so forth that was a
major part of it
about the uniform the flag the the
discipline the marching in step the
collective swearing of allegiances and
oaths and so forth I think has a has an
influence in orienting those male youth
toward toward what breaks out and more I
remember this is at a time in the early
20th century where very few people went
to college and the role that colleges
now play as sort of holding pens for
young males after they got out of high
school they don't want to live at home
so they go to college and then they they
can do you know a certain amount of
badass stuff but it won't be really
destructive and you go and say they look
at the history of college sports in
America it was deliberately constructed
after the Civil War as an outlet for for
the energies that had led to the Civil
War so the people who were promoting
football in the 1870s 1880s we're really
thought well we'll get this out of their
systems because young man who can't find
the sex partner and of course they
couldn't find the sex partner you know
what choice do they have they could
masturbate that would turn that make
them crazy and so that was prohibited
they could become gay but that would
mean you'd have a whole country full of
sissies and that was prohibited or they
could fight and they could fight on a
battlefield or they could fight on a
football field but it was felt that this
is what
what young men what young men are like
there's a lot of truth to that I think
but it's doesn't mean that it's always
regulated in the same fashion so when
you look at that period down to the end
of World War two and perhaps a bit later
you find out just the Boy Scouts but
also the Hitler youcan't the young
pioneers in the Soviet Union the
mobilisation of youth is a great
phenomenon of the early 20th century and
indeed the notion of youth culture
almost impossible to find it exemplified
prior to the early 20th century this is
when sports arise you don't now baseball
you know it's just so slow that it's
hard to quite compare it to other sports
that's earlier but but the big team
sports and the association of sports
particularly with college education
comes in the 20th century plus the
professionalization of sports and the
creation of the modern Olympics so
between youth movements and sports
activities the idea that young men are
being taken in hand by society in new
ways I think is you can easily argue
that and that as they are taken in hand
in new ways the ways available to them
are open to regimentation you know
indoctrination and and strenuous or
indeed violent activity and you can find
this pretty much all over the world you
have the
there are various proto-fascist usually
when they're not police cops we call
them proto-fascist but you know there
are various sort of proto-fascist youth
groups in other countries of the night
in the early 20th century and you could
look up the dates for the creation of
ministries of youth and ministries of
sports they would all fall into this
general period so there was a I don't
want to overuse word revolution but
there was certainly a a profound change
in the in the institutional forms for
socializing young males in the early in
the first half of the 20th century the
bad half of the 20th century this is
also when when youth fiction comes to be
recognized as opposed to children's
books children's books go back to the
18th century but the idea of books aimed
at adolescence is something of the of
the early 20th century and there you get
the idea of the young male as an
adventurer oh this is the Tom Swift
books the radio boys books
eventually the Hardy Boys I mean these
you know rubber-stamp
you know terrible novels that will that
came out by the score and that boys
gobbled up but of course society was
also gobbling up crime fiction which is
another it's more of a perennial but
it's it was more for adults and for boys
but they they eventually come together
in the invention of a comic book in the
night in the mid 1930s
I'll put off you know talking about
comics but not at the moment
interestingly there is the role of this
kind of fiction generally is not
recognized but in Thomas Pynchon's
not his most recent novel but the one
before the most recent one was called
against the day it's of a book of almost
unlimited length huge book I haven't
even pinched in specialists I know I
haven't read the book oh it's really
quite good but in it he has characters
whom he introduces who are known as the
chums of chance who are exactly like the
radio boys or something like that they
are fictional characters projected as
really living of the turn of the century
I'm travelling around the world in an
Zeppelin boys together having adventures
and he really sort of captures the youth
imagination of that of that era that
there was something special or a Hugh
you also brings to mind the modern
pentathlon where the activities you
engaged in were supposed to be the
activities and you might experience if
you were a messenger in during the in
the war with the army you might have to
fight one ton set one touch up a you'd
have to shoot a gun to have to swim a
river you'd have to ride a horse you'd
have to run and deliver your message and
that was the modern pentathlon the
militarization of sports and the or the
about the militarization it's pretty
badly the the intersection between male
youth culture violent activity and
sports and military I don't think was
ever as great as it was in the first
half of 20th century
because when you go back farther you
find that getting people into the army
was off in a matter of kidnapping them
and beating them up and then shooting
them if they left the front lines the
idea that they would go willingly and
enthusiastically into the military was
not an issue in the 18th century and not
through most of the 19th century except
perhaps for the early French Revolution
armies but by the World War one as I as
I mentioned last week people went
eagerly to war an eagerly to war not
just the officers who always want to you
know do what they're trained to do but
the with the rank-and-file as well so
then we get to the to the question of of
a long peace and whether something
happened after World War two
the Cold War is considered by Pinker to
be kind of a triumph you know the the
systematic mechanization of war to kill
more and more and more had been
ratcheted up and then when the
possibility of killing vastly more arose
it never happened and that that is sort
of a triumph well yes it was and it
still hasn't happened but I'm more
interested in what happened to two young
men and whether the world after World
War two is different with respect to the
to the socialization of men in the in
the risk-taking you know killing age
group whether that whether there are
changes perhaps it strikes me because
I'm someone who was just starting out my
my professional career during the
Vietnam War ii-era
and the anti-war movement of that time
was a very shaping influence for people
like me
of course there been anti-war movements
before but any war movements in the
Vietnam era had very little to do with
war exhaustion in terms of human losses
almost everyone who was in the anti-war
movement was not in the war and most of
them did not know anyone who was in the
war the war as usual was being fought by
people from humbler social classes than
those who attended Columbia or Harvard
and yet the passion against the war
once was profound now part of this was
the counterculture desire to get away
from uniforms to get away from
regimentation to go off and you know
live in a commune or smoke dope or play
guitar or wear bell-bottom trousers
whatever you going to do you know milk a
goat but the rejection of the the sort
of regimented life that male youth have
had up to that point was pretty
pronounced so that when you had the
great youth revolts of 1968 which
occurred in Tokyo in Mexico City in
Paris in New York I don't think it was a
simply a localized phenomenon I think
you had a vast dissatisfaction with the
way in which society treated young
people and that that was manifested in
this country in an anti-war move in
other countries in an anti state
movement or an anti university movement
or something of that sort that it wasn't
just a question of the Vietnam War and
this brings me back to two comic books
maybe it seemed improbable to you but in
1970 a comic book said
had begun in the 1930s early superhero
comic books Superman and Batman in the
format whereby they were delivered every
week to drugstores and you want a comic
book rack and you would go to every week
and last week's comics would have been
taken away and the new weeks would be
put out in the same way that the
magazines were so they were just
produced they were very low quality in
production drawing and so forth and then
in the 1950s they fell into a deep slump
cause partly by the allegation that the
boy sidekicks of superheroes were were
victims of pedophile superheroes so that
Robin was considered a victim no Green
Arrow and speedy speedy the poor thing
and and for fear of congressional
regulation after congressional hearings
comic-book industry entry introduced an
industry code that essentially took the
violence and the gore and the pretty
much everything interesting out of the
comic books in the industry essentially
collapsed it reconstructs itself at the
end of the 60s and kenny the seventies
in two forms one are the counterculture
comic books of the hippies liked that
are chrome and Fritz the Cat and things
like that but the other was a rebirth of
the of the superhero and in 1970
DC Comics introduced a new character
named Darkseid Darkseid is on currently
on the list of the the six the most
villainous evil person ever to appear in
the comic book universe you can find
that list online from the top hundred
villains Darkseid was a supernatural
character I had quick walk reading
comics by that time but I found myself
in Iran waiting for a good friend to get
leave time so we could go exploring in
the meantime babysitting for his kids
who had a trunk of comic books so I read
them all and what I discovered just blew
my mind
Superman was no longer an impotent
Superman could win a battle but he would
always going to lose the war and all
even more important all of the
fundamental institutions of society had
now been undermined by Darkseid who
worked through all sorts of front
organizations and so forth so the Daily
Planet the newspaper that employed Clark
Kent had been bought up by a television
conglomerate and the head of the
conglomerate was an agent of Darkseid
everywhere you went major industries
government offices they were all now
corrupted and the level of the
corruption was beyond anything a
superhero could do anything about and it
was so evident that the that the
counterculture
hatred of the CIA the US government the
army and so forth had penetrated the
comic-book industry I be I found it was
quite fascinating same time Robert
Ludlum was writing his sort of paranoid
novels for adults but what was
interesting about the comic book
industry is that the structure the
industry had changed they no longer
distributed to drug stores which and no
longer had comic-book racks but they
sold to comic book stores and they sold
on a different basis from trade press
books the trade press you can send you
know a thousand copies of a new
bestseller like the one donkey solution
to a bookseller and after three weeks
they've sold no copies only send them
back to the publisher and they simply
pulp the remainder or remainder them
because you had free returns from a
trade press comic book industry didn't
give you free returns if a comic book
store bought four copies of of an issue
than their suck with them and it meant
that the industry became very strongly
oriented toward demand-side thinking if
if you couldn't sell it you didn't buy
it so now you had young males and
precisely the age group to fight wars
who had their own literature they were
sure nobody but they were reading it and
they were generally right had no
advertising outside the environmentally
comic bookstore and the industry was
incredibly responsive to the demand side
because the dealers would have stock it
if they couldn't sell it so what happens
from then on is that you can look at
what are the ideas that are attracting
violent males or potentially violent
males
ages 12 to 25 what is it they they
really really like to read because they
now have their private literature and
one of the things you can do is to say
here's what they were reading in 1970
and when they're say 15 years old and
you add 20 years they're 35 and now
they've been socialized in that
direction and you can actually trace the
the evolution of topics in comic books
to the with a time lag of about 20 years
to the evolution of the outlook of of
takeover generation of males in our
society and what was so striking was
that the the the suspicion of
institutions that you had in the early
70s that was going into the the reading
library a secret reading library of
every you know literate boy in the
country was devastating it was totally
different from what you had with Batman
and Superman and Captain Marvel or
Captain America or even GI Joe of 1950
it was no longer standing up for America
for the American Way it was saying that
these superheroes were doing their best
in a society in which all the
institutions were profoundly corrupt it
was almost antithetical to the idea of
going to war for those institutions that
you were reading about as being corrupt
as you move along and I I don't have
time to go into it but you can actually
trace the change of topics over time and
see how they manifest themselves because
eventually of course
comic books become the primary source of
movies because the the comic-book
readers grow up and start to make movies
and they make movies reflecting their
views so that say a movie like Robocop
which is based on the notion of of the
corruption of the city of Detroit really
made a difference
now that's become a bit of a cliche and
so we move on to other things right now
if you're trying to see where things are
going look at the religious comic books
not the ones that that praise religion
or the ones that see religion has a
profound source of corruption read the
preacher series or the pilgrim series or
some of the ones like that it's it's
really quite a you know quite
interesting particularly since some of
those are clearly aimed at Baptists boys
from Texas who are reading them secretly
you know to make up for for how they
feel and Sunday being stuck there at
church um so what what I think has
happened and I patient taking comic
books but you could multiply this by
videogames multiply this by internet
activities the idea that you're ever
going to have in Western society at
least a generation of young men who are
really drawn to wearing uniforms and
marching together and being represented
by a banner and so forth and therefore
mobilize Abul in a fairly easily
conceived fashion for a big war
I think that's gone I don't think it has
to do with democracy and only it has to
do with trained I think it has to do
with international government
organization I think it has to do with
the way in which people are particularly
young men are socialized and that
it is now different if you do play a
first-person shooter game it really
changes you you know by generation it
was doom and quake and things like that
but but putting you in a battlefield
that's an electronic battlefield and
allowing you to simply Massacre them all
it was kind of cool but you wouldn't
want to do it and I've argued in a my
book on animals hundred surgeries and
hamburgers that you have a a reciprocal
relationship between the were real world
and the world of the imagination that
when we quit killing animals in real
life or at least allowing people to see
animals killed in real life when we quit
recognizing animal reproduction
the way everybody in 1900 did they saw
animal slaughtered they saw animals
having intercourse being born now nobody
ever sees an animal other than a pet and
the pet was probably neutered and you
certainly don't see animals being killed
but as that happened you had a vast
increase in in the experience of killing
and sexuality in the imaginary in the
amount in the imaginary that people
started seeing on television or movies
but even more on the internet the things
that they did not see in the real world
what this amounts to is that let's go
back to the example of well of sex for
example the old notion of sex from the
early 20th century was that if you are
inclined to do it and you are not
married you should either suppress that
thought or do it in some sort of secret
and non non evil fashion what you should
not do is masturbate because what
happens when you masturbate is that you
imagine sex doing it was far better than
imagining it imagining it was
fundamentally wrong because it meant
that you had a diseased mind and you
would soon go crazy and probably die and
there at least you'd go blind because
imagining it would be you know how could
you how could you carry on once you'd
imagined such things so you have these
draconian punishments and everything
particularly the Boy Scouts having to do
with the masturbation then we reach a
period of the 1970s when when you say
well let's let's Skype and take our
clothes off and masturbate together
wouldn't that be fun or you know let's
do it all of the imagination and that's
becomes the world of today you know the
internet world the you know somebody who
has telephone sex never gets pregnant
you cannot mishandle the telephone that
badly um so
but the point is that once you move
things into the imagination then the
scale the scaling up becomes unlimited
you know sex is just sex but sex in the
imagination can turn into all sorts of
things or seeing a chicken have its head
cut off and squirting blood all over and
running around without a head it's
pretty disgusting but in the imagination
you can have people who are spraying
blood all over the place
1969 the squib is invented so that you
can shoot someone in the movies and have
the blood squirt out from then on we've
had more and more blood and I think that
we have moved a tremendous amount of our
violence into the imaginary realm and
out of the realm of organized
socialization so my inclination is to
agree that with respect to the the idea
of peace being probably with us for a
long time that those societies that have
made this transition to a to a world of
the violent imagination rather than the
violent reality and to have put the
militarization of male youth aside or
the male youth for put it aside all by
themselves that they're going to have a
very hard time conducting substantial
warfare but that doesn't apply to
everyone in the world and when you go
back and look now at certain guerrilla
organizations or terrorist organizations
what do you find is that they still have
the old notion of socialization of
bringing the Shabaab the boys together
to do something violent
so I think we're in a period of
transition Cory might hope that we can
move into a largely post violent
post-war era but there were not there
yet on a world basis but but we may but
we may achieve it just not for the
reasons that Steven Pinker puts forward